Abraham Lincoln vampire hunter now with
the title like that do I really need to
explain the plot well let's do it anyway
this movie opens with the young Abraham
Lincoln very young like he's a boy and
everything and he witnesses a vampire
kill his mother as he grows up he kind
of starts this course of vengeance he
wants to find this guy who killed his
mother he meets this guy who's a vampire
hunter who trains him to be a vampire
hunter and he goes out every night
killing vampires hoping to find this guy
who murdered his mother
now it's Abraham Lincoln and that's
really the novelty of this movie is the
fact that you get to see Abraham Lincoln
killing vampires I think that's really
cool that's a great idea that is such a
great idea and I was really looking
forward to seeing this movie and seeing
like what they can do with it for the
first half of this movie there's lots of
vampire stuff going on lots of vamp
deaths vamp faces or just coming at you
out of the screen popping out of the 3d
which ain't bad it's alright 3d ain't
bad I thought Benjamin Walker did a
really good job as Abe Lincoln I liked
his character I like the way he
portrayed his character I did a nice job
you meet Mary Elizabeth Winstead who's
freaking hot and she decides to get into
a relationship with Abe and everything
then the halfway point happens Abe is
like in his 50s and he's a president
already and he doesn't like killing
vamps anymore and there's like this long
drawn-out period of nothing really for
like a good 25 minutes to a half an hour
and the movie really slowed down to me
the novelty of seeing Abraham Lincoln
killing vampires is seeing a guy who
looks like Abe Lincoln you know he's got
the beard got the Hat is got the suit he
actually looks like Abe Lincoln killing
vampires that sounds cool but for the
first half of the movie even though the
action was there and everything it's
still it was just really a guy cuz he
looked nothing like Abe Lincoln until
the last half of the film and so it was
really just a guy killing vampires so
for me I really didn't get to see Abe
good old Honest Abe killing vamps until
the finale of the movie really I really
thought there was a lot of potential
with this movie to be really good and
this one we could really go both ways
you know when you go in this movie it
could either be horrible I mean it could
just be like wow or it could be really
fun you know for me this movie was kind
of in the middle and my biggest problem
with this movie is that it takes itself
dreadfully serious it really does with a
movie like this with the title like that
it's gotta be really self-aware you know
it has to be aware of the fact that it's
Abe Lincoln the slashing down vampires
you know it shouldn't be taken so
seriously but they really treat this as
like a straightforward drama
to be a movie like Kill Bill you know I
mean it needs to have smiles and has to
have humor the humorous sucked right out
of this movie there are no laughs in
this movie there's really no smiles it's
honestly kind of dark and sad if you saw
wanted which is by the same director as
this film then you understand the kind
of action you're gonna see it's a lot of
very over produced CGI sped up really
quick and then slow mode all of a sudden
and then sped up again in slow mode
again and you just kind of have to go
with that and that's not really the
problem I have of the movie it's just
the fact that they took it so seriously
and it just sucked all the life out of
this movie that could have been there it
should have been pulpy and fun and
entertaining if you go to this movie and
you just want to see some bloody vampire
deaths
you'll get that for sure that it's
definitely in this movie I think
Benjamin Walker does good is Abe Lincoln
but for the most part the writing in
this movie and the way that they set the
tone for everything just really sucked
the life out of it for me and I didn't
really enjoy it that much I'm giving
here I'm Lincoln vampire hunter se it
could have been better it wasn't awful
it just it just wasn't quite there for
me so guys I'd like to know what's your
favorite vampire movie let me know in
the comments below if you guys missed it
the schmoes no and I are in the middle
of a collaboration or viewing the
previous six Batman films before Dark
Knight Rises comes out in July we did
the first Batman movie it's on their
Channel right now I put the link in the
description below if you want to go
check that out and on Thursday we're
gonna have Batman Returns right here on
this channel I hope you guys enjoy that
and look forward to that if you liked
this review you can subscribe to my
channel and get stuck mine eyes